[Music]
hi everyone very good morning
to you it is seven o'clock you're very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news the race
to offer every adult in the uk a vaccine
is entering the home straight
according to nhs leaders but can the
same be said for the relaxation of
lockdown
we'll ask the environment secretary
george eustis in just a moment
also this morning we're joined by the
chair of the health select committee
jeremy hunt
to discuss the toll it's taken on the
nation's health workers
also this morning
[Music]
england what a turnaround in 12 months
a certain former england manager joins
us at half past nine with just a few
days to go
before the team's bid for european glory
kicks off who does he think
might be our star player and in addition
to that a bit of this
[Music]
another black lifeguard leaving what we
thought we
knew what we thought we
knew some clearly didn't black
lives matter the leader of the dance
troupe
diversity ashley bancho is on the show
at a quarter to ten
fresh from winning a bafta for that now
famous
black lives matter routine it's tuesday
the 8th of june vaccine booster six
months since the first kobe jab was
given over 25's get the call
but fresh fears over freedom day going
ahead
anger and disappointment as
holidaymakers rush back from portugal to
dodge the ambulance deadline
which has passed in the last few hours
3.7 tonnes of drugs 20 threats to kill
and 45 million in cash how police in
australia
helped infiltrate an encrypted messaging
service to deal a hammer blow to
organized crime
the england and wales cricket board says
a second cricketer is being investigated
over historical offensive social media
posts
death spiral activists accuse world
leaders of not
doing enough to help save our oceans
from climate change
and destructive fishing and it's hotting
up this week with heat wave conditions
for some spots this weekend
until then it's not looking warm and
settles everywhere i'll have the details
for you
later
[Music]
hello everybody we've come a long way in
the last six months since the first
vaccine was administered
in the uk to 91 year old margaret keenan
since then more than 68 million doses
have been administered and from today
over 25s in england are also being
offered their jab
but elsewhere there remains uncertainty
over whether the prime minister will
give the green light to the final stage
of lifting the lockdown
with concerns over the delta variant
leading to reports the so-called freedom
day
could be delayed shingi mari k reports
six months ago at a hospital in coventry
this ninety-year-old grandmother made
history
since margaret keenan became the first
person in the world to receive a kovid
jab
the vaccine rollout has continued at
speed there has been a total of around
68 million vaccines given
with more than 40 million people getting
their first dose and almost 27 million
people receiving both
and now from today millions of young
adults will get their turn
it's such an important milestone uh
opening up
access to jabs to the final priority
group the 18
to 29 year olds and that's why when the
25 to 29 year olds in the next few days
get that text message
inviting them to come in it's really
important that they
book that appointment and get their
first job
plenty of people are excited to seize on
this invitation
they see immunity as a chance to
continue enjoying recently restored
freedoms of added protection
i'm very happy about that i was waiting
for that day
and now i can finally make an
appointment and
that's good news it makes you feel a lot
more comfortable i'll say that
knowing that you've taken the
precautions necessary
last week even i was queuing at the st
thomas hospital in westminster trying to
get the leftover ones but
even then like i think there's so many
people trying to trying to get it
but with cases of the delta variant
rising
others warn the vaccine rollout is not
enough to prevent a third wave
we've been discussing whether or not
we're going into a serious
third wave and i don't think we can
possibly wait any longer
this is the evidence of another wave
appearing
if scenes like these are anything to go
by we can expect long queues when
vaccine centers open their doors to 20
somethings
they have waited long enough shinki
maruike
sky news environment secretary is with
us mr eustis good morning
lovely to see you uh freedom day may be
pushed back at least a fortnight is what
we're hearing in the papers this morning
um what credence are we giving to that
well look the prime minister's always
said he's going to take this a step at a
time
and that with each set of relaxations
they're going to basically assess the
data when we get there so we can't make
the final assessment until the 14th of
june that's what he said uh all along
and we obviously don't rule anything out
the critical test really
is are those people with the new variant
are
people who've had the vaccine getting
infected they've been a couple of cases
i
think not many it's encouraging and
we're obviously making good progress on
the on the vaccination
but it's too early to say yes what we'll
do we'll be announcing that next monday
okay um apparently there was a briefing
yesterday to the prime minister
and others from valance and witty
suggesting the figures are at this stage
grim
uh which side are you on on moving it
back or not as we speak today
well i'm not sure i would say it's grim
in that we we've seen an increase
yes well we've seen an increase
obviously in the uh
infection rate so that's gone up uh
ticked up if you look at the graph that
we're all seeing now in the news every
evening it's gone up that's for sure
but what we're not seeing at the moment
is that growth in
hospitalizations associated with it and
that's because we know that if people
have the vaccine particularly once
they've had the second jab of the
vaccine
it actually does give them immunity to
this new strain that's around but there
have been a few cases of people who've
had the double jab who've then gone on
still
to get that uh to get infected again and
that's why we need to look very closely
at this
watch the news in the morning as well as
the evening yes
of course one of the biggest factors of
course is the um
india variant if only we closed our
border a little bit earlier when we did
with pakistan and bangladesh that might
have made all the difference
well this has been a dynamic situation
all along things moving very quickly
we closed the border to bangladesh
because
we were seeing if the people arriving
from there a higher incidence
of the coronavirus and you know although
you know we also know that india was
testing uh much more so
the the numbers that they were picking
up you'd expect them to pick up more
because they were doing more testing as
soon as we saw
that surge in india as well we obviously
closed the border so
we we review this all of the time the
the travel bans
every few weeks we're reviewing who's in
those lists
and india was added as soon as the data
supported that well i'm just looking at
figures i mean ed conway
um our economics editor was looking at
the figures on our behalf quite recently
25th of march to the 7th of april and
these are nhs testers trace figures
bangladesh was at 3.7 they were put
on the red list india was at 5.1 percent
of people arriving
uh had tested positive and yet they
weren't
put on the red list why do you think
that was well look um this was obviously
a few weeks ago
my understanding is that uh india had a
higher
uh incidence rate that it was reporting
but that's because it was doing more
testing
figures here not not what happened in
india but when people were arriving in
this country
of those arriving according to the nhs
test and trace there were more a
bigger percentage of people from india
who were positive than bangladesh and
yet we put bangladesh on the red list
well i'm i'm not sure i mean um the data
as i understand yes well as i understand
it and
matt hancock made this clear at the time
uh initially
uh the uh incidence of the uh virus in
people arriving from india was lower
and overall while they were reporting uh
high numbers of cases
that's because they were doing more
testing now i don't know the date of
that particular there may be the
march to the 7th of april right well um
i haven't seen
that particular data i have to be honest
but my understanding is
that the reason we put bangladesh on the
list earlier is
that they uh they were they were seeing
higher instances
i mean i mean their figures were lower
not they're the ones at the top the top
bar
yes because we're lower well i know that
they were um they were testing less and
so reporting fewer cases no i'm talking
about nhs test and trace once people
came into the uk
well we were also looking at factors
such as their ability to do
uh genome sequencing and you know we're
looking at all of this when we assess
other countries
their ability to be able to pick up new
variants of concern for instance
uh and india does have better testing in
place than other countries
i think about the figures in the uk not
about what happened in india or indeed
the other two countries that we talked
about
was it a political decision no it's not
so they regularly review this
based on recommendations that come from
sage and the the joint biosecurity
committee
they look at that data and they make
those assessments at the time but we
were very keen for the prime minister to
go to india at that time around that
period
weren't we because you wanted to do a
trip we wanted to do a trade deal
with india so it was in the interests
of the british government to keep the
border open with india well
i mean it's fair to say that well i i
don't that's not um
the reason so the prime minister was yes
due to travel to india
uh but we then put india on the red list
uh and that obviously
was cancelled a couple of weeks before
he was due to go that was a couple of
weeks after you did it with pakistan and
bangladesh yes but
i mean as i said my understanding is and
this was covered at great length at the
time
though we had fewer concerns about india
at the time because they
were testing more and also because uh on
arrivals
my understanding is that they they were
showing a lower incidence rate
certainly lower than pakistan but not
lower than bangladesh by any major in
bangladesh
uh was at 3.7 india was at 5.1
when they were arriving here in the
united kingdom i was reading a report
from um
he is associate professor in cellular
microbiology dr simon clark
and he was saying that uh he felt that
there was probably a political element
because the uk wanted a trade deal
with india and the prime minister wanted
to go that's nonsense
yes that's been dealt with at the time
matt hancock's been asked
i think he's explained a great length
that the criteria that we've been
applying when assessing who should be on
the red list
what the incidence rate is that's
reported but also
their capacity to do testing their
capacity to pick up variants of concern
um the uh incidents of those that are
arriving so there's a range of factors
that are looked at
it's not just one single measure yeah
and india was added as soon as we uh
saw a spike in rates and as soon as we
thought saw there was a reason to do it
and as the rest as they say is history
uh on reflection do you think it's
appropriate that the british government
apologize
for not closing the border sooner well
look we're going to have a
a review into the whole pandemic and how
it was conducted there's going to be an
inquiry that starts next year that's
going to look
a great depth at everything right from
the beginning of this pandemic right the
way through
how people reacted if there were lessons
to be learned then we should wait for
that inquiry to do its work and then
we'll learn any lessons we certainly uh
closed the border very quickly
with portugal haven't we people had to
get in by four o'clock this morning or
thereabouts
swiftly moved from the green list to the
amber list do you think
probably on balance is better that
people holiday at home this year
well look basically now there's no uh
the very few countries on that uh green
list
our advice all along has been uh don't
travel unless it's absolutely
necessary obviously we had hoped uh with
these uh
three categories that we had we'd hoped
that situation would be improving in
other parts of the world that we'd be
able to progressively add other
countries to the green list
sadly that's not the situation we do
have this new variant of concern
first identified in india that is now
cropping up in other countries
and we've just got to take a very
cautious approach the most important
thing is that we can
continue to open up our own economy get
back to life
as normal here the biggest threat to
that is that we would have a variant
come from another country that would
find a way of getting around the vaccine
that's the biggest uh threat to us at
the moment that's why we should be
really cautious yeah
so do you think people i don't know
would you rather holiday in iceland or
would you go down to your home county of
cornwall
i shall be yeah i'm sure but what should
people
what should people do should they risk a
green list given that people have had to
scurry back very quickly
well look people will make their own uh
individual
judgments on what do you think it's a
very dynamic situation it is
um i will be staying at home i have no
intention of uh traveling or going on
a holiday abroad this summer some people
may but they have to understand that
there are obviously
risks in doing so because it is a
dynamic uh situation but
i think most people will probably decide
this year to
stay at home holiday at home we've got
some fabulous
places to visit in this part of the
country not least of course cornwall
although it'll be a very very busy
summer i'm sure then and that's the
right thing to do
i i think um my my advice to people
would be um
a holiday at home we've got some great
places here there aren't many countries
that are on that
red list but obviously you know some
people will want to travel abroad
there are still a small number of
countries on that green list
if they wanted to do that they can but
obviously they'll have to understand
there are risks in doing so as well and
with some of them get the map out as
well i didn't know where some of those
places were
a lot of g7 leaders of course coming to
your home
county do we have a special relationship
with the us
i think we always have uh had a special
relationship with the united states um
where important uh allies
uh have been now ever since the second
world war we've been through a lot
together as uh as countries so yes we
are important allies uh always have been
regardless of who's in the white house i
read the
prime minister said today that it makes
us sound needy and
weak to say we have a special
relationship well
um it depends how you use it if you see
the special
relationship as meaning that um we
always have to um
go go to the united states to um uh you
know work with them on things
people may see it that way but actually
a special relationship could also be a
special bond of trust where you work
together on things and that's what
our relationship is i mean we we do need
a trade deal with them and we would be
weak without it
we wouldn't be weak without a trade deal
with the united states no but obviously
we would like to do a trade deal with
the united states
we'd be weaker with that one wouldn't we
well um you know
we we've got trade deals with other
countries around the world we do a lot
of trade with the united states we have
a trade surplus with them they are an
important trading partner
uh of course it would be good to um get
a trade deal with the united states if
we could get one on the right terms
uh brussels are very cross with us at
the moment as far as
trade deals are concerned there they're
threatening a trade war
if the uk overrides the brexit treaty uh
had a government minister sitting where
you are
yesterday um and she said that the deal
with the northern ireland border in or
the the irish sea border
is harder than anticipated do you agree
well i think um what you have to bear in
mind is that the protocol
always envisaged that the both parties
would show best endeavors
to make the northern ireland protocol
work and that included
recognizing that northern ireland was an
integral part of the uk
and that you should support the free
flow of goods to northern ireland what
we really need
the eu to do is to respect that part of
the protocol
and put in place sensible measures to
remove things like the nonsensical ban
on
selling sausages or chicken nuggets to
northern ireland
not just requiring paperwork but
actually having an outright ban on some
of those goods that clearly
doesn't make sense it had always been
envisaged that there'd be a
a joint committee process and
specialized committees that would look
at some of these technical matters
to iron out the creases and we just need
the european union now to engage in that
process and
talks i think are starting this week um
indeed so lord frost
very much engaged but do you acknowledge
that it is harder than anticipated this
deal
even though you were told at the time by
former prime ministers
leader of the cbi people like that that
it would
it would be a very difficult process
well i
am what i would say is um we'd obviously
hope that the european union
would engage more fully in the joint
committee process
and in those specialized committees to
identify solutions to
some of the issues such as a ban on the
sale of sausages in northern ireland
which doesn't make any sense
other issues as well such as if you're
delivering goods
and you're a supermarket and you're
going direct to store
uh in northern ireland there's no risk
of those goods uh ending up into in the
irish republic or in the european union
in the single market
so that could be recognized and special
measures could be put in place
so there are solutions that are there um
using digital technologies to make this
work we're committed to
uh making it work but we just need the
european union to engage in that process
to iron out those issues
sausage and chicken mcnugget wards that
sounds enticing let's see where that
takes us over the next
few months i wanted to ask you about um
a report from jeremy hunt uh he used to
be the foreign secretary was before that
the health secretary as you know a
colleague
of yours he's now chairman of the health
and social care
select committee um he says nhs staff
are suffering
from burnout and they are not being
supported the way that they need to be
by the government
what would you say in response well look
we had a manifesto commitment to recruit
more nurses an extra fifty 000 we've
already recruited
12 000 nurses you know we are expanding
funding for the nhs we are recruiting
more staff
yes of course they've had a difficult
year um if you're dealing with a
pandemic
as they've had to it's been a very
difficult time uh they've done
extraordinarily well
we are doing all we can to support them
but um the critical thing
there is that's what he said well i'm
not sure what more we can do they've
worked very hard
well um there's been a pay rise and
there's a review looking at that issue
uh again but we're we're also recruiting
more staff and if
um if the issue is that they feel under
pressure and it's
that's entirely understandable having
been through this pandemic
one of the things that we're doing is
recruiting more staff and we've already
recruited an extra 12 000 nurses
just before i let you go animal
protection what's the plan
animal protection yeah um i know that's
why you were here
oh no oceans it's today is world's uh
oceans today uh ocean's day and we are
um
announcing today that we're going to
accept the recommendations of a review
that we will put in place highly
protected marine areas this is where you
would
prevent any activity there whether it's
extraction such as fishing or aggregates
or indeed even wind wind farms in order
to enable these areas to
fully recover and there are a lot of
benefits for the environment in doing
that so we're going to
pilot some of those sites okay world
ocean day how are you going to celebrate
it
uh well i should be doing it it's very
close to our heart here at sky we love
the oceans as you know we have
massive campaigns today we do and i
think the public are very concerned
about
plastics in our asians and very
concerned about some of those
threats to marine life and indeed
overfishing and it's one of the
big issues actually that'll be on g7
indeed uh you you're going down there
this week
i should be going down on wednesday
night uh it's happening just across
sometimes bay my constituencies at the
other side of that i've got a number of
events
that i'll be attending fantastic it's
good to talk to you thank you so much
for taking the time to join us this
morning thank you still to come on the
program
for you we're going to be asking the
environment secretary as
we heard there about the what's
happening in portugal
officially added to the ambulance
forcing british
holidaymakers to dash home before new
isolation rules kicked in
it's led to anger and frustration as
ashna harinag reports
weaving through the arrivals gate just
in time narrowly escaping
self-isolation
hours ago portugal was taken off the
shrinking green travel list
for many that beat the deadline it meant
both a huge cost
and inconvenience she cheated when we
left we were told
nothing would change before the 10th
obviously we're out there on our family
vacation
uh they changed it to the 7th which just
was stressed out the whole holiday what
choice have you got
who can stand for 10 days you know i'm
self-employed
uh it's just not feasible my wife can do
it
and it's pretty much everyone coming off
the planes in the same boat how does it
make you feel about
travel in the future the fact that
things are so unpredictable i think the
confidence has gone isn't it because
we booked the holiday on the basis that
it was greenless country
and we didn't really think for one
second they would change it this quickly
the queue started early at faro airport
many joining
some 10 000 british tourists who've
flown home over the past few days
an inevitable reaction the decimated
airline industry cannot stand to see
any longer some of the most powerful
players in air travel
meeting to express their frustration
i've been vaccinated i've been shielding
i've done
everything i've been asked to do i still
don't understand why i can't get on
airplane
and travel their proposal
to heal the wounds a uk and u.s travel
corridor
aviation bosses cite the success of the
vaccine rollout on both sides of the
atlantic
it would be significant as it would mean
they could start to claw back the
billions of pounds
lost by the industry
the movement on these runways is driven
by data
and decisions from afar those
tantalizing destinations
still feel so far away ash naharinag sky
news
gatwick still to come on the programme
for you at
a quarter two speaking to the chief
marketing officer of paddy
and that's kristen valet wurz
as mps on the health committee warn nhs
and social care staff burnout has
reached emergency levels the committee
chair jeremy hunt joins us at
five plus eight twenty first day
speaking
to journalists and royal biographer
angela levin about the
release of meghan markle's new
children's book the bench
the arrival of her daughter lily bette
diana
3.7 tons of drugs 20 threats to kill
and 45 million in cash has been
uncovered by
police in australia who infiltrated an
encrypted messaging service
targeting organized crime sky news
australia reporter gabrielle power
is in sydney forest hello gabrielle good
morning
we are good evening where you are tell
us more about this story
okay this is one of the largest and most
significant police operations in
australia's history
criminals and underworld figures were
using this encrypted app
called anom to communicate with one
another and they were plotting
murders they were trafficking billions
of dollars worth of drugs and also
engaging in other
large-scale dangerous criminal activity
but little did they know that this app
anom was actually designed by police and
it was designed by police
to catch them and over three years the
australian federal police were working
with the fbi
and they read in real time more than 25
million messages as a result they've now
seized 3 000 kilograms worth of drugs
they've seized 45 million dollars
in cash and as a result 200 australian
people have been arrested and they've
been charged okay
okay good to talk to you thanks very
much for the update thank you
time for a look at this morning's other
main stories for you now here on the
breakfast show the electoral boundary
commission has announced plans for the
biggest shake-up of parliamentary
constituencies in england
in decades among those affected would be
the labour leader secretary of stama
whose london suite of hoben and saint
pancras set
to be altered and renamed as kentish
town and bloomsbury
the new plans would see england gain 10
additional seats at the expense
of wales due to lose 8 and scotland
which will be down
2. the canadian man accused of killing
four members of a muslim family in
ontario
has been charged with four counts of
first degree murder
and one of attempted murder the driver
plowed a pickup truck
into the family of five on sunday
leaving only one survivor
detectives investigating the attack
described it as an islamophobic hate
crime
second england cricketer is being
investigated over historical offensive
social media posts
the england and wales cricket board have
said within the last
um couple of hours or so back late last
night wasn't it let's get more on this
from our correspondent charlotte lomas
hi charlotte tell us more
well we know now a second england
cricketer is being investigated we don't
know
who this is the website wisdom.com
did publish the content of this tweet
but
concealed the identity of the england
cricketer because it's believed he was
under 16 at the time and now the england
cricket board have confirmed they're
looking into
these new claims obviously of course
they come after the suspension
of england bowler ollie robinson who was
suspended from international cricket
for historical offensive tweets that he
made in 2012 and 2013 when he was 18 and
19 years old
he's now 27. he has apologized for those
tweets and said he's embarrassed by
those
sexist and racist tweets um we have just
uh heard from the prime minister
and the culture secretary oliver bowden
who described his suspension
as over the top
okay lovely thank you
right let's have a look at what's
happening as far as the weather is
concerned now nas is standing by it was
lovely yesterday a bit chilly outside
of the sun but what's happening today
today it's looking fine and dry for many
areas and in fact
through this week it's going to get
hotter some spots
this weekend could reach heat wave
criteria
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it is going to become
warmer over the next few days in fact
for some spots this weekend
it is going to be rather hot and we
could reach heatwave criteria
in some areas and that's due to high
pressure that will be dominating by this
weekend but until then there's still
some atlantic influence going on for
the next few days bringing cloudy skies
this morning across many western parts
of ireland
northern ireland western scotland too
some patchy light rain and drizzle
whereas further south and east as you
can see it's a mainly dry and bright
start
for this morning it is rather cool out
there murky as well around some southern
and
eastern coastal areas going into this
afternoon though
lots of sunshine on offer once again
with the winds being light as well we've
generally got high pressure dominating
across many parts of england well so
it's a fine
settled afternoon feeling very warm
across parts of the east
not so warm further north and west where
it stays quite cloudy with that lack of
sunshine
patchy light rain and drizzle continuing
across many parts of ireland northern
ireland
and over scotland northeast scotland
seen some showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i think it's fair to say isn't it that
we all want to wind down a little bit
when we reach
retirement age and it's no different for
land mines sniffing rodent
magawa there he is after five years of
service the african giant
pouched rat known as a hirorat is
bringing the curtain down on a stellar
career
in cambodia magawa is part of belgian
charity
apop which is an organization that
trains rats to save lives by alerting
human handlers to land mines
and unexploded bombs so they can safely
be removed
the charity says that during his career
magawa has
cleared the equivalent of 31 football
pitches
and discovered 71 landmines and 38 items
of unexploded ordnance which is
pretty impressive for a rat so now it's
time for him to have
a well earned rest
good for him hearing from holidaymakers
in just a few moments
test providers and also business owners
as travel
is expected to be made more difficult
for those wanting a getaway
this summer
[Music]
business uh has been uh good you know we
we've
had strong sales throughout the pandemic
and in particular clotted cream has been
a a product that
many people across the nation have been
choosing to
treat themselves with um while they've
you know been been at home more often um
and that's been fantastic and you know
we we're now gearing up for
what we're expecting to be a a very busy
summer here in cornwall
um and uh the the staycation boom that
is
is going on throughout the uk
the reason that jam needs to go on first
is that you would you would love to have
this with a uh
a hot scone and if you put your clotted
cream onto a hot scone it will just melt
away so you have that cool layer of jam
to keep the cream pristine sitting on
top as the
as the prize part of your cream tea so
there is there is science behind us as
well as a lot of traditions so
uh that that's why we think it's fatal
conflict
we are so so last year we saw as i said
the the sales of clotted cream go up by
some 38
across um across the uk and and that was
driven by
um more people uh buying clotted cream
that previously had them which was
fantastic and
and more so outside of the the south
west um
it's natural heartland for potted cream
um
and now like i said with the uh the
staycation boom coming and
our expectation that the hospitality
industry in cornwall will
will be um benefiting from that um we've
actually
increased the days of the week that
we're producing by an extra day and
that's created 35
job opportunities um within our business
in in production distribution and
and back of house stuff so it's very
good news
my name is fatima zanzilla the founder
of ikista from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
exchange if you recycle to get a tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
morning again everybody goodness me in
the last half hour
have we heard from a government minister
the death knell
for holidays abroad this year
the environment secretary on the
programme in the last few minutes
and this is uh what he was saying more
or less we'll talk about it in more
details it comes after british
holidaymakers
flooded back from portugal late last
night with the country being taken off
the green list
in the last few hours this is what he
said
people will make their own uh individual
um judgments on what do you think i mean
it's a very dynamic situation
it is um i will be staying at home i
have no intention of uh
traveling or going on a holiday abroad
this summer some people may
but they have to understand that there
are obviously risks in doing so because
it is a dynamic
situation but i think most people will
probably decide this year to
stay at home holiday at home we've got
some fabulous
places to visit in this part of the
country not least of course cornwall
although it'll be a very very busy
summer i'm sure then that's the right
thing to do
i think um my advice to people would be
um
a holiday at home we've got some great
places here there aren't many countries
that are on that
uh red list but obviously you know some
people will want to travel abroad
there are still a small number of
countries on that green list
uh if they want to do that they can but
obviously they'll have to understand
there are risks in doing so as well
tamara is here goodness i wasn't
expecting him to say
no we weren't expecting him to say that
and that's because although
many people have booked trips to places
which are on the ambulance including of
course portugal which
went on to the ambulance in the early
hours of this morning because this list
is reviewed every three weeks and they'd
hope that as
we came to later in the summer to the
school holidays in july and august
trips to other european countries may be
possible
and of course when this traffic light
system was announced
the idea was and grant chaps the
transport secretary said at the time
that this would be a safe return to
international travel
what george eustis just told you was
that although it was the government's
intention that more and more countries
would come onto the green list and there
would be more options
that hasn't happened and that really the
biggest risk
to what we've achieved with the vaccine
program and and opening up
is that the idea that a variant might
come from a different country and derail
it so his advice he says is to stay in
the uk
all summer and he said he'll be doing
that in cornwall uh i think it might be
quite pricey to book a
holiday in cornwall if you're looking at
doing so now but
certainly the government minister has
really put a dampener on
people's hopes for having a holiday
abroad later in the summer and it does
look potentially
put it to him as well that freedom day
might be pushed back a fortnight or so
but he was not having it that that had
anything to do
with the uk being slow some say
in closing the border with india that's
right his message on the opening up on
june the 21st was what we've heard from
the government
for the last 10 days they're looking at
the data closely they'll take that
decision
on monday and we hear that there's
wrangling behind the scenes
about whether they should relax some
freedoms but for example keep people
working from home but yes questions
about the indian variant
continue and whether they were too slow
to put it on the red list okay for now
tomorrow thank you tomorrow with us
throughout the course of the programme
of course um as you've been hearing
there are there were certainly a fleet
of airline passengers
rushing back to the uk in an effort to
avoid quarantine restrictions from
portugal last night
our producer john jarman documented his
journey home
here in pharaoh airport in the algarve
in southern portugal
we have to change our flights come back
a day early
from our lovely holiday down here it's
been it's been beautiful
but the ambulance announcement was
something that did change our plans so
we
were probably one of the lucky ones
coming back 24 hours early
wasn't too bad at all but for others
we've heard people who had to cut
short their holidays significantly and
there was a bit of a mad rush for
flights when the announcement
was made so when we were booking flights
we saw they went up
significantly within the space of five
minutes firstly we
went on to the the website to book
flights and they were about 90 pounds
within five minutes they'd shot up to
150.
this is actually the second time we've
been at this airport in the last three
days because
we had to get a covered test
here a couple of days ago which meant we
had to queue for a couple of hours
but it was worth it so that we didn't
have the stress of doing that today
so as you can see it's a little bit
busier here but it's not too bad
and obviously we've been very lucky to
go abroad during a pandemic
not everyone gets to do that john
is with us now hello to john
morning k morning morning i am fine now
given everything that's happened was it
worth the trip
uh i think it was worth the trip yeah it
was worth the trip it was certainly
a bit of a bit of added stress uh at
certain parts of the holiday
when it got moved to the ambulance it
was something that we had to act
quite quickly on in terms of booking
flights as i discussed there
uh briefly when we when we heard about
the ambulance announcement
on thursday we went on to try and book
flights
to come back a day early and they were
shooting up genuinely every five
ten minutes in terms of going up 50
pounds and then 100 pounds so that was
something that
certainly added a little bit of stress
and it's just
just another added element that people
have got to bear in mind if they're
going on
on holiday abroad this summer you know
we had to get a test before we went out
there
then we had to get a test um before we
came back and then i've got to do a test
tomorrow two days after we come back as
well
and certainly with the algarve because
of the announcement
there was a shortage of tests over the
weekend in terms of
lots of people trying to book a lab so
they could get tests and come back
before the amber announcement
came into place so that just was another
element of sort of um stress to the
holiday but
it was it was worth it to answer your
question i think uh
it was it was a lovely week away we
managed to luckily we were
only have to come back about 24 hours
early it's just something
for holidaymakers to bear in mind when
they're going away this summer
indeed so but as a result of course
you're having to spend your birthday
today
in the uk when you were expecting to
spend it in portugal
as a result i'll tell you what i'll do
i'll take you to cornwall with me
at the weekend for the g7 how does that
sound
that sounds lovely probably not quite as
relaxing as portugal but still a nice
little trick see what we can do we'll
see what we can do lovely to see you jj
thank you
thanks dave thank you meantime an
airport covered testing provider has
worn gloves can't cope with the volume
of tests needed for holidaymakers to go
abroad they're saying airline passengers
should prepare for expected delays and
disappointments
this summer uh now joined by the
managing director of
akea life and that's ben paglia hello to
you ben it's good to see you thanks for
joining us this morning how dire is it
hi kate thanks for having me on um yeah
so
i think the situation at the moment is
not bad because the amount of people
traveling is quite small um
the issue that we've seen um in the last
few weeks
at our own testing facility is quite an
increased number of people having to use
our express services
largely because they haven't received
some of the postal tests
that they've been expecting and even
when they have received them they
haven't necessarily
been given the results um on time and as
a result of that they're having to pay
extra
to get tested again at a facility like
ourselves um
at liverpool airport missed flights test
flights delayed or lost altogether
is it actually worth going on holiday
abroad this year
uh good question um i think it is it is
a lot more stressful now
i don't think anybody could deny that as
um as the gentleman before me was
pointing out there's a lot of tests to
be done
before you fly out before you fly back
and then when you fly when you when you
arrive back in the country
i think i think if we all get better
organized with it and there's a lot more
clarity
for every individual as to what to get
and when to get it and where to get it i
actually think it can be quite
streamlined
um so i do still think holidays can be
worthwhile and not too stressful
i i'm not a big fan of the postal
services that a lot of
airline providers and laboratories are
are now offering
um i understand the need to try and make
things cheaper i i fully support that
but that might not necessarily need to
be at the expense of people's uh stress
levels in their holidays
because one of the challenges with the
postal services you're relying on so
many moving parts
with myself what i would do is
i would find uh clinic-based testing
providers to
um bring the stress level down
make sure it's done by a professional
send back to the lab with an internal
career system et cetera
and you've got a really good customer
support team to help
with any questions or queries but at the
moment i think it's still a bit
piecemeal
and we've seen a big number of people
having
quite traumatic journeys because they
haven't got their results through
and they're on the way to the airport
when do you think it's going to get
better
when are these laboratory testing
conditions going to stabilize when's the
postal service going to be able to
um good cope i mean it's it's and the
minute for me it's not so much about
testing capacity i think there's a huge
amount of testing capacity within the
laboratory system i think it's more the
front end
the um the logistics the customer
service side of it
um i think the labs need to a lot of the
labs need to up their game in that in
that
in that respect in order to be able to
provide
what they're promising so i think it
will come with time
um i'd just like to see more
collaborations with providers like
ourselves to work better
as opposed to just going necessarily
direct to the consumer
um and trying to sell them cheap tests
which might not necessarily mean
them getting the results that they want
at the time that they need them
so i do think it will come with time um
but i i'd like to see more collaboration
with providers like ourselves
on the ground at the airports in order
to provide services better
bring prices down at that end and
hopefully over the next few weeks and
months that can happen
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us this morning very much
appreciated thank you
someone who has been very badly impacted
on
the fact that portugal moved from green
to the amber list
from four o'clock this morning they
stand to lose out due to that
lack of tourist traffic and that is
chitra stern
and she's the owner and founding board
member of martinel
family resorts in portugal hello t
we've spoken before you were very
hopeful that
this summer would improve for you guys
what impact has the decision
made by the british government had on
your business
well key um it was the sudden impact
um that we had to face uh you know
we were uh it was announced that we were
on the green list and we had lots of
bookings
and then suddenly uh you know we
had to face this uh sudden surge of
people uh having to book their return
flights
um i mean thankfully it was uh may half
term so people were leaving on sunday
anyway
but um it was it was a difficult um
thing to face and of course we're facing
lots of cancellations now
600 uh emails and phone calls
and um it's it's it hasn't been easy
um how have you dealt with those sudden
cancellations what's that
have you got enough um tourists from
other countries to continue uh with
the hotels being staying open or not
well um we are getting bookings from
other countries such as france
uh switzerland germany luxembourg even
belgium
um however um the uk's
you know british business represents
around half
of our business in the algarve and uh in
fact in kashkaish even though it's not
traditionally
uh full uh with british or even half
full uh with british guests
this may have to we had a hotel full of
british guests so
um i i would say uh with um
you know travel patterns are changing
and uh you know there's more travel
within europe but we can't hope to
replace
uh british business uh with other
business right now because
uh you know we're trying we're trying
uh do you think brit do you think it's a
tough situation
sorry do you think brits should still
come even if you are on the amber list
you know well you know living here uh it
feels different of course i'm not
in london or the uk right now um you
know we've
uh we feel we've controlled uh the cases
quite well there's a lot of mask wearing
still
there are lots of rules that apply
everywhere and the vaccination rate is
progressing very well since we got
supplies
and um uh you know it
there are some guests around uh 20
of the calls are saying you know we'll
we'll shorten our holiday will still
come
and face the quarantine uh you know
we'll do that extra test
uh when we get back home so um i think
it's not just me
even uh some british people are still
coming on holiday
and if you're booking a villa uh with a
pool
or you know all of our hotels have a lot
of space around
um uh you know it depends on where
you're going so
uh i would say uh do it if you
if you can afford to um take that
holiday
with these extra restrictions because um
people have been waiting a long time to
spend time with their family
so i think it's uh you know people
should
take that special trip if they can okay
good to talk to you thanks a lot thank
you
thank you kay all the best bye now
there's been
a big warning today about our oceans
our science correspondent thomas more
has more
veiled in a light mist what happens at
sea is out of sight and out of mind
but greenpeace is on a mission to expose
destructive fishing practices
in british waters for six months its
boats will patrol ostensibly protected
areas off the south coast
looking for super trawlers with nets a
mile long that scoop up
everything in the way a couple of miles
offshore we found
david in his small boat he can't compete
there's barely any fish left the nets i
use now for maxwell they're 300 yards
long is to use 100 yards
put it in for after they've got a day's
work and when i kneel
i put the net in three times yesterday
13 fish
operation ocean witness is also looking
for evidence of this
the gouged almost lifeless devastation
left by
trawlers dragging heavy fishing gear
along the bottom
right now the uk government stands up on
the world stage and claims to be a
leader
in ocean protection because it's got all
of these marine protected areas
surrounding its coastline
however inside these protected areas
you're still allowed to do
pretty much whatever you like so we're
seeing bottom twirling that's fishing
where you're
dragging nets along the bottom we're
seeing uh dredging we're seeing all
kinds of destructive fishing that is
completely unsustainable the uk has set
aside 64
offshore areas that on paper protect
habitats like reefs and corals
but in 62 of them trawlers last year
dragged heavy fishing gear along the
bottom
for a total of 68 000 hours
that's a rise of 10 from 2019
greenpeace wants the practice band in
conservation areas
the ocean quickly bounces back once it's
given
proper protection research suggests that
within five years there are so many fish
that they spill out into surrounding
areas
where fishing boats can still operate
it's a win-win
for both the environment and the
industry
the government has announced plans for a
pilot scheme of highly protected zones
with a ban
on all damaging activities but
greenpeace says it's nowhere near enough
30 percent of the ocean needs meaningful
protection
to sustain marine life and keep fish on
the menu
thomas more sky news in new haven
well the professional association of
diving instructors has created a charity
dedicated to
driving location action for global ocean
conservation i want to talk about that
in more detail i'm going to take you all
the way
to california to speak to the chief
marketing officer of paddy
and that's kristin valette worth hello
to you it's good to see you thank you so
much for joining us
on world ocean's day um
what are you hoping to achieve with this
initiative
thank you kay it's so nice to be here
and a happy good morning to you on
celebration of world oceans day uh what
we're really
helping hoping to achieve is to really
achieve a balance between humanity and
ocean
what you've just described there and the
good reporting that's just been done has
shown that there are tremendous threats
facing our oceans and we as citizens of
this planet
need to do a better job to find that
balance between humanity
and ocean and we can only do that if we
believe that there are solutions in
place
so we have started this foundation to
help not only divers get involved
but uh you know also non-divers get
involved in being part of the solution
instead of just looking at some of the
problems that exist that are quite real
problems
what sort of debris are we talking about
well that's a great question there is a
ton of marine debris
out in our oceans and uh getting more
and more
through some of the marine debris that's
coming through the rivers and waterways
so in order to rid the debris uh
and of our oceans we really need to get
into
the source in which that's coming from
uh in partnerships we can accomplish
that
and we really truly can rid our oceans
of debris
not just through what you're seeing on
screen here which is certainly the
divers taking actions themselves at the
local level
but uh but actually putting interceptors
in to
collect the debris before it gets to the
ocean and that's truly the key
we need divers to really understand and
validate the data
so that we can you know uh we have a
unique you know
um site insight in mind is what divers
see i think one of your reporters said
it's out of sight out of mind for so
many people
but divers have that unique perspective
where we can actually see what's going
on under the sea
and by doing so we can actually provide
valuable data to be able to
send that back to see if some of these
partnerships that we're
talking about are actually working and
intercepting some of the uh
you know debris that is going into the
ocean and really prevent that from
happening and that's our goal
and what sort of marine species is most
at risk
great question there are quite a few
marine species at risk
and really what needs to be protected is
the apex predators
uh they are the most vulnerable believe
it or not for example
sharks and rays are quite vulnerable and
when they get overfished
it puts an imbalance in the entire
population and marine habitats
so we need to look and do additional
monitoring to understand
what those fish populations are the
marine mammal populations are
the apex predator populations are so
that we can
really look at legislative issues to put
better bans on things like shark fishing
and some of those apex predators which
are so valuable to keeping
the balance of our ecosystems at play
kristin how much longer have we got left
to make a difference
we've got to start today okay that's the
key we are
hopeful you know as long as you combine
hope and action we believe that
certainly anything is possible
and i think one of uh one of the
individuals just before me was was
talking in your video there
about there's things that we can do the
marine protected areas and and proper
enforcement
with marine protection is what's going
to be critical
you know protecting 30 of our oceans by
2030
has to be done we just can't wait any
longer so we're talking about in the
next decade we need to take
real meaningful action in order to save
our oceans and that's certainly what we
intend to do
uh again with divers but also
non-diverse
midnight where you are i better let you
get some sleep and then you can enjoy
world ocean day
tomorrow christian valletta uh paddy uh
chief marketing officer thank you for
joining us thanks a lot
thank you king thank you and uh for more
news like that and stories from the
people trying to stop
climate change you can watch the daily
climate show here on sky news
you can see my friend and colleague anna
jones every day at 6
30 and 9 30 p.m
or if you're on the go you can download
and listen to the latest edition of our
weekly
climate cast podcast available now
wherever
you get your podcast as they say
in the trade what's happening as far as
the weather's concerned here's uh nars
hi nels
hi good morning it's looking fine and
sunny for most places today not
everywhere though
and then as we head into the weekend it
really will be hotting up for some spots
we could have
a heat wave
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's going to be hotting up
into this weekend as the high pressure
builds and dominates the scene across
the uk but until then we've still got
some atlantic influence bringing
cloudier skies
across parts of ireland particularly
western parts of ireland northern
ireland and western scotland for today
it's a dull start across these areas
this morning with patchy light rain and
drizzle that will continue across these
parts this afternoon
elsewhere lots of sunshine first thing
quite a cool start murky as well around
southern and eastern coast but
bright into this afternoon but eastern
parts of scotland i think turning
cloudier perhaps for parts of northern
england as well
but otherwise warm and sunny and dry
elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways